la muerte de la reina Isabel II volcó
algunas miradas a más de 12.000
kilómetros de Londres Allí se encuentran
las Islas malvinas un archipiélago que
carecía de población autóctona y cuyos
primeros ocupantes fueron europeos tras
la conquista y que ha sido el principal
punto de fricción en las relaciones
entre Argentina y Reino Unido el momento
más tenso llegó en 1982 cuando se desató
el conflicto entre los dos países para
disputar la soberanía de las Islas uno
en el que murieron más de 600 argentinos
y 255 británicos y a pesar de la
búsqueda Isabel segunda de mantener
cierta distancia con los temas políticos
la reina tuvo audiencias públicas con
margaret thatcher entonces primera
ministra de Reino Unido y quien lideró
la ofensiva de sus fuerzas armadas en
las Islas
además su hijo el príncipe Andrew peleó
en la guerra de las malvinas
tres décadas después llegó una de las
declaraciones más polémicas de la
monarca al hacer referencia a las Islas
falkland como se reconoce al
archipiélago en Reino Unido
mi gobierno garantizará la seguridad del
buen gobierno y el desarrollo de los
territorios de ultramar incluso mediante
la protección del derecho de los
habitantes de las Islas falkland y de
los gibraltareños a determinar Su futuro
político
la locución se dio en un momento crítico
pocos meses después se celebró un
referendo en el que los habitantes de
las malvinas decidieron si querían
seguir bajo la administración británica
dicha opción se impuso con más de 92% de
los votos pero el plebiscito fue
cuestionado por Argentina asegurando que
fue organizado por británicos para
británicos y no fue reconocido por
Naciones Unidas el asunto de las
malvinas también hizo presencia en la
celebración de los 70 años de la Reina
Isabel II en el trono cuando la corona
británica le dio a Puerto argentino o
Stanley la capital de las malvinas el
rango de Ciudad un estatus condenado por
Argentina
el anuncio de la corona británica sobre
Puerto argentino expone el carácter
colonial de La ilegal e ilegítima
ocupación sobre nuestras Islas malvinas
para hacer claro el territorio fue
usurpado a la Argentina hace 189 años
por una invasión militar el gobierno de
las Islas malvinas se pronunció tras el
fallecimiento de la reina destacando el
servicio de la monarca para su país y su
gente un comunicado que contrasta con la
percepción de buena parte de la sociedad
Argentina que considera las malvinas
como parte de su territorio me hubiera
gustado que la reina antes de
fallecernos no nos devo Como hizo con
Hong Kong no que también era una colonia
británica y las Inglaterra la la
liberado de alguna manera no
tras un escueto comunicado del gobierno
argentino la gran incógnita es como
manejara el Rey Carlos III la relación
con las malvinas